at least seven people have been killed
during pro-democracy protests in sudan
groups opposing military rule have been
holding mass rallies ever since a coup
last october the army crackdown on the
demonstrations has become increasingly
violent more than a hundred people have
died since the protests began
eight months ago
all right for more now i'm joined on the
phone by journalist mohammed amin he is
in khartoum muhammad what have you seen
in the course of just today
now yes actually uh
the process has continued since
today's morning and is still ongoing and
uh in the worst of that the violence of
the police and security organs
are ongoing as well and
this goal has increased over the past
two years from five to seven days
while like dozens of critical
cases
still in the hospital
the matter that makes the situation more
tense that the security organs have also
raided some hospitals in roman and in
cartoon but on the other hand the
protesters have made new tactics of
doing like several settings
in many neighborhoods in bahrain
and
back from around the presidential palace
to inside the neighborhood
[Music]
let me just let me ask you what has what
has made this situation
um deteriorate in the past few months i
mean the situation you know it's it's
changed significantly hasn't it
yes actually the violence have increased
because of the pressure that made
on the military group
over the past two months
from the protesters on the ground
and
you know that
there is also a huge pressure on
the military leaders from the
international community and of all the
funds
to the sudan and this is
also reflected uh badly on the economic
situation in the country so this is why
uh
new uh people also are joining the
project and today they were like
uh hundreds of tons of thousands
protested uh during this afternoon today
around the presidential ballot
and this is why the
the the military regime is
increasing the violence and
yesterday they used
the live footage to use uh rubber
bullets using teargas and a lot of
tools of violence against the protesters
journalist mohammed amin reporting
tonight with the latest from khartoum
thank you